we need more contrarians we all knew the
earth revolved around the Sun until we
didn't we all knew south africa would
trance tappan at Rugby until we didn't
contrarians are always willing to say
maybe we're wrong it always pays to keep
an open mind even when we think it's
totally obvious what's true you'll often
be wrong but that's okay because most of
the time so is everyone else so how do
you do it one be the devil's advocate
when Catholics nominate someone to be a
saint they always have to have a devil's
advocate to hear both sides of the story
be that guy too when everyone suddenly
agrees on something they don't know much
about assume they're wrong when a new
story breaks whoever gets to put the
first spin on it usually gets to decide
what we think about it watch out for
them three be polite but don't worry
about annoying a few people sometimes
people get annoyed when you doubt them
but I think the more annoyed they get
the more doubts they have 24 when you
find a sacred cow that's when you really
onto something people don't make things
sacred unless they don't have any actual
evidence for them as a contrarian your
job is to find the sacred cows and
slaughter them with those four steps you
too can be a contrarian
you